(dramatic music)
- I don't understand why
they're going up there.
Literally to the top of the
rockiest part of the cliff.
- [Narrator] Once at the
top of the 80-meter cliffs,
they rest until it's
time to return to the sea
in search of food.
- That last little section is really steep
and they just, it's
really steep, that bit.
(dramatic music)
- One's gonna go, this
one right on the edge.
(gentle music)
There's probably two or 300 dead walrus
on like a half-mile stretch of beach here.
They're exhausted 'cause they have to swim
a hundred miles now to get
to food, and then coming
back here 'cause it's
the only place to sleep.
They used to sleep on the
ice, dive down and eat food,
sleep on the ice, easy.
And now they're swimming a hundred miles,
coming to this place, climbing cliffs,
and they're just exhausted
and falling down,
and either being killed falling
or just crushing each other
'cause there's several thousand
crammed onto little tiny bits of beaches.
- This is a sad reality of climate change.
They'd be on the ice right
now if they could be,
but there's no option but to come to land.
And they're just a danger to themselves.
Really hard to watch and
witness this, it's just--
(gentle music)
It's just so heart breaking.